i'll be honest i haven't eaten much of
the fast food pizza it's like
sacrilegious honestly i really think our
grandparents are rolling in their grave
my grandmother's like she don't take
after me i'm sorry no nothing i'm sorry
[Music]
nicole last episode with georgia was no
joke
you lost
but you gotta pick yourself up
dush yourself off and do what you got to
do well i really want to make you guys
proud i'm going to give it my best and
we'll see what happens the last
challenge you know we went very
traditional stuff from the old country
but
today's challenge is totally different
it's
fast food pizzas the pizzerias that
everybody knows across the country we're
talking about pizza hut and dominoes but
of course
you're gonna bring them to new heights
that's what i do though that's what i do
you already know so you're facing off
against the heavy hitter nick d giovanni
he was our master chef he has some
credentials he's out there he's got a
lot of followers on social media makes a
lot of great plates and he's going to be
bringing his a game today nicole you
think you could beat him i got to beat
him i'm coming off of l i got to do what
i got to do i'm going to try my best
[Music]
nick thank you so much for being here
thank you for having me so what are you
making today so i'm actually going to do
my best at replicating domino's pizza
but at home here so i'm just i'm using
i'm using typical ingredients but i'm
try i'm going to try to nail the
domino's pizza i have a feeling you're
gonna do a great job so why did you want
to do dominoes versus doing pizza hut
honestly it comes fully down to the
crust domino's paints that garlic butter
on the edge it's delicious
i like that a lot so i think just the
crust alone is what kind of won me over
for the dominoes should we get into it
yeah let's go
alright so to start super simple i have
some pretty typical dough here and i'm
gonna roll that out i i'm gonna try
again to kind of replicate every
possible step here so what is so great
about domino's pizza dough honestly i
see it as a pretty kind of classic dough
i feel like it's got that really nice
balance of kind of a chewy interior oh
and and also that really nice kind of
crispy on the edge but again fluffy airy
crust i'm also using a little semolina
when i kind of roll this out here okay
um and i'm also going to bake it on kind
of a wire rack that's what they do so my
dough looks good yes
looks great so i'm going to go ahead now
and just start building it okay
so sauce sauce nice like slightly sweet
slightly tangy tomato sauce i can see
the little specks of like the basil and
the different stuff in there which i
like all right so for the cheese i'm
gonna do a blend of mozzarella and
provolone so i got all my cheese on
there and as you can see i loaded it on
yeah i like my cheese i like it too this
is a mixture of a little bit of olive
oil garlic some butter i like that
butter olive oil me too yeah and then a
little bit of parsley so okay i again i
try to mimic what they do on that crust
i'm gonna gently paint this on the crust
all the way around i feel like it it
fries your dough i always paint my pizza
crust oh okay
yeah so we have that
and then we go on to that with just a
tiny tiny little bit of parmesan cheese
parmesan cheese i feel like that's a
good touch right yes and then fennel
seed
that's gonna be a secret ingredient
today that's amazing and if you're a
huge garlic lover you can put more
garlic i'll put a little bit more garlic
salt
and garlic powder yeah and then i think
i think this pizza looks ready to go it
does
[Music]
wow
yes that looks really good check the
booties what's it doing that's the booty
shot i've never seen domino's pizza look
like that they need to call you no no
this looks good here we go
that looks amazing here we go look at
that guys i'm gonna go for the crush
first oh you know what i me too one two
three okay
[Music]
wow
oh the crust is no joke so given that
this was a challenge for me to try to
recreate a domino's pizza or if not make
it a little bit better how do you think
how do you think i did i definitely
think you made it better for sure number
one i could taste the burst of flavors
in the crust and and on the pizza
and i like the way it has like that
sharpness from the provolone i think you
did phenomenal i love it it's a good
slice of pizza yeah if i went out to a
really good beach place and i got this
i'd be
more than happy nick you did amazing
well are you ready for a pizza hut i'm
excited to try it out okay well let's go
let's see it
so today i'm making my personal favorite
pizza hut supreme supreme is classic
italian crumble mushrooms red onions
pepperonis black olives and green
peppers
so what i did was i had my dough rise in
the pan so i could make it nice and
fluffy and airy i watched the uh
training video so
now i'll be able to work a piece of hut
yeah so i'm gonna do it just the way
they said to do it so we're gonna do is
i'm gonna ladle some sauce
and we're gonna put this directly on the
dough and we're gonna watch the edges i
tried to replicate their sauce and i
felt like it was strong in oregano i
tasted a hint of rosemary i could be
wrong and you know garlic i feel like
you did your research a lot more than i
did here so what i saw was they put some
cheese on the bottom just a little bit
to start it right okay so what i'm gonna
do is i'm going to start it off if i
remember correctly with pepperoni okay
oh they have a special layering system
oh they had a whole training video pizza
hut for me was a treat dominoes was
something we ordered at home pizza hut
is something we went in really yeah okay
and now you're here trying out pizza i
know i'm out pizza in the hot ah i love
that nick
okay so now we're gonna add our green
peppers another thing i did was i kind
of dehydrated my toppings a little bit
so when it's spring too much water i'm
hoping it doesn't spring a lot of water
that's a very cool idea i'm gonna add a
little italian sausage crumble and i'm
gonna add some mushrooms black olives
and then some onions
and then
i'm gonna add some more mozzarella on
top that's the most toppings i've ever
seen put on a pizza really yeah by far
oh my gosh well i like plain pizza too
but this is the supreme so i made a
garlic parmesan butter okay because they
also add that to theirs
so i'm just gonna put that on the outer
crust and then this is what they call
fairy dust pecorino a little bit of
oregano so it's not too overpowering
and also garlic okay all of my toppings
are on we're going to throw this in at
500 for about i'm thinking let's try
eight minutes okay all right let's see
it
[Music]
[Applause]
let's see if i out piece up the hut
booyah
oh
look at that look at the bottom of that
the bottom looks good looks amazing well
the proof is in the taste tell me what
you think
i would say that's a perfect pizza crust
i really would thank you so much it's
perfect don't you agree yeah i'm trying
to get a job you know what i like about
this you get a different bite with every
bite it's different i got a little
mushroom there i see next time i'm gonna
get some olive some of that red onion i
like that it's a journey need a creative
you know just piece of hood holla at
your girl nikki did an excellent job and
i'm really happy with mine too but let's
see what frank and josephine thinks
fingers crossed fingers crossed
[Music]
wow all right frank first up we got a
pizza hut supreme pizza i'll be honest i
haven't eaten much of the fast food
pizza it's like sacrilegious honestly i
really think our grandparents are
rolling in their grave my grandmother's
like she don't take it after me i'm
sorry no nothing i'm sorry but this
looks like what they look like on tv
like that the big crust it's in the pan
all right all right we got a crust back
together crust feels good yes how many
toppings on this thing
but you know what it's got a nice crispy
crust it's got a nice little uh
caramelization on the bottom it kind of
stands up
this kind of tastes like a detroit style
pizza right mm-hmm
we definitely got that pan that that
pizza pan thing going on well i'll tell
you one thing they definitely did a
great job with getting that buttery
flavor that pizza hut has whoever made
this
did a really good job of
making the crust sturdy enough to kind
of hold up all these toppings you know
oh yeah i think if pizza hut really
tasted like this i would eat it my only
note would be is uh the amount of oil i
see on the bottom of this but besides
that it was a fantastic rendition of
pizza hut frank we got to save room i
like this are you ready we got another
one i'm ready i'm ready bring it on
all right next up we got a domino's
classic cheese pizza i'm interested by
this crust it looks yeah what do you
think before you even touch it what do
you think it tastes like because i see
some i see the herbs i see some
maybe rosemary parsley sometimes is that
fennel seeds fennel yeah i don't know it
looks to me like a domino's pizza like
they always got a lot of cheese
was this green used on the bottom it's
got that same texture that those
dominoes pizzas have on the bottom the
sauce is there the cheese is there
there's the pull it's great but i gotta
say it doesn't scream dominoes the crust
does i completely agree with you about
the crush if you're talking about
original dominoes
it looks like a level up of that they
always go heavy with the cheese and all
of these you know fast food concepts
they always want to make it look like a
ninja turtle cartoon or something so
when you when you pull the freaking
pizza out it stretches like that's the
most important thing frank this is gonna
really be a tough one
we're gonna have to talk this over this
is a tough one we're gonna have to see
eye to eye on next no yeah i gotta we
gotta talk behind the scenes a little
bit seriously
[Music]
nick nicole you guys did the impossible
pizza hut and domino's pizza i'm really
like surprised i'm gonna actually say
this
i actually enjoyed it it was fantastic
so honestly this was very difficult
starting over here with the pizza hot
pie i mean i thought it was very well
structured i thought it was made really
well i ate my entire slice if that came
out of a pizza hut box i would be able
to tell the difference on how good the
ingredients are but i wouldn't be able
to tell the difference on how it looked
on the other hand this pizza i also
thought was was great and this is like a
level up it has a nice airy crust the
bubbles what i really liked was that
detail on the bottom just that
cross-hatched look which is very
reminiscent of pizza that goes on a
conveyor oven you know all right i think
at this point we're both just begging to
know who won so
who got it all right well
i gotta say it's this one right here the
pizza hut i mean
all the way yeah wow you nailed it
you nailed it thank you that was
incredible that was incredible i have to
say nick gave me stiff competition
for your money hell [ __ ] yeah when i
saw and tasted the crust it was like it
was too perfect i'm okay with i'm okay
with the wind there no but you're look
at your crust i'm staring at air it's
beautiful you did a fantastic job on the
money pizza should be calling you give
her a consultant check make me she just
stepped your pizza off like 10 levels
this season is gonna be amazing because
you two are so freaking hard yo it's so
hard to get past these two i'm telling
you i just want to thank you so much
nick your pizza was kick ass and gave me
stiff competition so thank you so much i
was proud to lose to you today that was
a damn good pizza
[Music]
you